des dizaines de chevaux mutilés à la une
des journaux retour sur une psychose
collective fondée sur un mensonge qui se
cache derrière les mutilations de
chevaux en France
c'est en alerte
des propriétaires de chevaux disaient je
fais mais en deux nuits avec mon fusil
si je vois quelqu'un je n'hésiterai pas
[Musique]
nous sommes près de Dieppe en Normandie
à la fin du printemps 2020 Pauline s
propriétaire de plusieurs chevaux alerte
la gendarmerie et la presse pour
dénoncer des actes de violence sur Lady
l'une de ses juments après s'être
absenté quelques heures en pleine
journée elle a découvert son animal
couché et mutilé la jument était encore
en vie elle a succombé peu de temps
après j'ai qu'une envie c'est de
retrouver l'enfoiré qui a fait ça elle
est connue dans la région de Dieppe
comme une amoureuse des chevaux c'est
quelqu'un qui s'est investi dans le
milieu associatif de la protection
animale et qui a entrepris à l'été 2019
de fonder une sorte de refuge de la
dernière chance pour des animaux qui
sont en premiers à l'abattoir
dans une caravane sur un terrain et elle
se met à adopter petit à petit à
recueillir des équidés mais pas
seulement il y a aussi d'autres animaux
et elle se retrouve à la tête d'une
petite ménagerie l'histoire de Pauline S
et de sa jument Lady fait écho à un
article publié quelques semaines plus
tôt il y a eu un article qui a beaucoup
tourné dans les milieux équestres c'est
un article du magazine le nouveau
détective qui a semé l'inquiétude parce
qu'il évoque un gang qui massacre des
chevaux à travers toute la France de
plus en plus de journaux rapportent des
cas de mutilation sur des équidés de son
côté Pauline s crée un groupe facebook
intitulé justice pour nos chevaux la
jeune femme sur laquelle j'ai enquêté va
jouer un rôle très important parce que
faute de recensement officiel justice
pour nos chevaux va devenir en quelque
sorte une référence ça devient un lieu
où les propriétaires se retrouvent
s'échangent des conseils et échange
aussi leurs angoisses sur mes chevaux
toute la nuit je prends ma ronde à une
certaine heure jusqu'au matin après
c'est ma voisine qui prend le relais
je fais mais en deux nuits avec mon
fusil si je vois quelqu'un j'hésiterais
pas oui
dans le commerce avec des cartouches en
caoutchouc alors que les gendarmes
multiplient les patrouilles dans
plusieurs départements pour rassurer les
propriétaires de chevaux une cellule
dédiée à l'enquête est ouverte à
l'échelle nationale des enquêteurs
friends phénomènes très au sérieux ils
comprennent pas bien pourquoi des
oreilles semblent prélever comme des
trophées on a vraiment intensifié notre
visibilité à proximité donc
décentréquestres des Haras des prêts
plusieurs pistes sont envisagés on
évoque des rituels sataniques des
mouvements sectaires on évoque aussi du
fétichisme et toutes ces pistes on les
retrouve dans une note des
renseignements territoriaux qui fuitent
dans Le Parisien
encore un cas d'attaque d'un animal dans
son pré les cas se succès des se
ressemblent des chevaux ont à nouveau
été retrouvés mutilés on peut même
parler de psychose à la fin du mois
d'août 2020 la gendarmerie de l'Yonne
publie le portrait-robot d'un agresseur
présumé la photo est partagée près de
500 000 fois sur Facebook le groupe
Justice pour nos chevaux compte
désormais plus de 20 000 membres la
fondatrice de ce groupe devient une
sorte d'experte et une porte-parole
assez naturelle des victimes j'ai
retracé les cas sur une carte de France
pour boire à peu près dans quel ensemble
de régions c'était et pour finir par me
rendre compte qu'au final il y avait
beaucoup plus de cas que ça et ça c'est
depuis la création la création du groupe
où je me rends compte que ça arrive
partout n'importe quand et chez
n'importe qui l'affaire dite des chevaux
mutilés tournent à la psychose
collective et prend une tournure
politique monsieur le ministre que
comptez-vous faire pour défendre les
équidés et défendre les animaux on est
aujourd'hui face à des actes d'une
cruauté d'une barbarie un qualifiable la
gendarmerie est pleinement mobilisée la
police est pleinement mobilisée au
moment où je vous parle c'est plus de
150 enquêtes qui ont été ouvertes et
dans la foulée le maison intérieur
Gérald Darmanin on appelle à la
mobilisation générale des Français pour
contribuer à l'enquête pour relever des
indices pour aider les enquêteurs je
voudrais décréter avec le ministre de
l'Agriculture la mobilisation générale
des Français de signaler tous les faits
tous les indices qui permett ent
d'arrêter les personnes qui commettent
ces faits extrêmement graves un numéro
vert est mise en place pour les
propriétaires de chevaux mutilés sur
Twitter plusieurs comptes se faisant
passer pour des médias s'amusent à
lancer une folle rumeur l'animateur
Nagui serait responsable des mutilations
sur les chevaux quand vous découvrez
votre jument mutiler et tuer les
enquêteurs eux pensent tout de suite à
des corbeaux c'est ce qui vous avait dit
c'est ce qu'ils m'ont dit dès le départ
oui après le une des interviews que
Pauline s’accorde à BFM TV c'est une
séquence qui a été très suivie par les
gens qui s'intéressent à la faire
n'importe quand et chez n'importe qui
une des personnes qui a été une de ces
très bonnes amies à tenter d'alerter en
postant un message sur ces sur ces
réseaux j'avais mis un mot sur justice
pour nos chevaux et du coup m'a bloqué
de ce groupe je sais pas si c'est elle
ou un modérateur en tout cas on m'a
banni elle savait que les animaux qui
étaient chez Pauline s à l'époque allait
mal elle m'a contacté pour faire famille
d'accueil pour une vieille jument qu'on
avait nous à l'association qui
s'appelait divine elle m'a dit qu'elle
faisait depuis en quelques mois
l'accueillante pour la Fondation
Brigitte Bardot elle me disait que
c'était des chevaux qui sortaient de
maltraitance donc c'est pour ça qu'il y
en a certains qui étaient maigres elle
veut sauver un maximum d'animaux la
difficulté c'est que c'est cette jeune
femme a des revenus assez modestes trop
modestes pour
nourrir et soigner correctement tous les
animaux qu'elle a recueillis ces animaux
commencent à avoir très faim pour
certains d'entre eux plusieurs meurent
un jour où je lui demande comment va
divine et elle me dit divine est morte
mais comme ça donc sans me donner
d'explications et donc du coup je lui
dis qu'est-ce qu'elle a eu et donc à me
dire le cœur a lâché il y a quelque
chose qui est bizarre donc j'ai dit je
vais écrire à la Fondation Bardot la
Fondation Bardot Macron à mon œil que
cette personne là jamais fait partie de
leur service et je trouvais ça vraiment
tordu après plusieurs mois de conflits
avec Pauline s sara a réussi à récupérer
tous les chevaux placés chez elle à la
fin de l'été 2020 Pauline S ne répond
plus aux sollicitations des journalistes
et disparaît elle a eu un contrôle
sanitaire on a commencé à lui retirer
plusieurs de ses animaux parce que les
autorités ont estimé qu'elle n'était pas
en mesure de s'en occuper correctement
en janvier 2021 Pauline s’est arrêté par
les gendarmes lors de sa garde à vue
elle reconnaît avoir tout inventé
le 6 juin une de ces chaînes qu'elle
aime beaucoup qui s'appelle Luna a
vraiment très fin et se jette sur une
jument qui elle-même est déjà très
affaiblie et la jument la jument meurt
quand elle voit sa chienne la gueule
ensanglantait elle a très très peur de
ce qui peut arriver à cette chaîne elle
a peur qu'on la lui est retire elle a
peur qu'elle soit tout un asiée alors
cette tienne est tout pour elle et tout
le mensonge qu'elle développe vise à
protéger cette chaîne et à la garder et
qu'une envie c'est de retrouver
l'enfoiré qui a fait ça elle s'engouffre
dans cette histoire des chevaux mutilés
dont on commence à parler dans l'unique
but de détourner l'attention en juin
2021 Pauline s est condamné à quatre
mois de prison avec sursis pour mauvais
traitement et dénonciation mensongère sa
chienne luna lui a été retirée et il lui
est désormais interdit de détenir un
animal et d'exercer une profession en
lien avec les chevaux à ce jour aucune
personne n'a été mise en cause dans
l'affaire des chevaux mutilés ce qui est
nouveau
c'est qu'on s'est mis à compter ce qu'on
ne compte jamais c'est à dire les morts
naturels les animaux qui se qui se
blessent dans les champs ou qui meurent
de leur belle mort sur l'ensemble de
l'année 2020 les gendarmes ont étudié
524k dans l'immense majorité des cas ils
ont abouti à la conclusion que c'était
bien des bords naturels et que des
charognards étaient les auteurs des
mutilations sur les 524 répertoriés les
enquêteurs estiment que 80 chevaux ont
été mutilés par la main de l'homme
[Musique]